there was a collective all in the
theater when we got Miss Angela Lansbury
oh well that's you that we can talk
about okay let's talk about this so I
believe this is her final project if I'm
not mistaken I know how much she means
to you what was it like to work with
I mean it was incredible it was yeah so
Angela Lansbury and also Stephen
Sondheim both have a cameo in one scene
in the movie and I did for anyone who
hasn't seen it I don't want to blow it
up too much it's just one little fun
moment that they have but what it meant
for me besides just how special it is to
have both of them in the movie
um it meant that I got to just spend 10
minutes with each of them to film these
this little moment and uh for me just
getting to meet them getting to tell
Angela Lansbury what her work meant to
me to only Sondheim about watching like
the filmed version of Sweeney Todd that
was on cable when I was a kid and how
that really kind of started me the
loving musical theater and I mean it was
just it felt like a very special
privilege to get to do that Halle Berry
I want to ask about the um hourly dong
the hourly dong
a conversation well so let's break it
down who it is yeah okay so the there's
there's a thing on Miles bronze Island
where every hour you hear like
and it's the hourly dong it goes up
every year and so that's uh that's a
reference to one one of my favorite
mystery movies Evil Under the Sun
there's a big thing in it with the
Noonday Gun and they shoot a cannon off
at noon every day but in the script it's
written as I think uh like the hourly
gong I think and one time when Edward
was saying it he said it wrong and said
the hourly dong and I said that's it
it's the hourly dong now he goes no no
no no I don't want to have to say that
you guys nope it's the hourly dong years
here that's it so now I'm so early on
yeah and so Joseph or love it just goes
down he goes down yeah yeah we were
working with him on the set of Poker
Face he's in an episode of this TV show
I'm doing with Natasha Leon called poker
face and Joe is the guest star of one of
those episodes and we just said I just
said okay you have to trust me just say
the word dong really loudly yeah and so
we got recorded him doing it and kind of
built it into a little musical thing all
right once a murder mysteries start
where did you get the idea for for the
sequel for a glass on you uh well I mean
it kind of started with um you know
coming off of the first one Daniel and I
even when we were making it we were
having so much fun we were like it would
be fun to keep doing these and the idea
was always kind of to take inspiration
from what Agatha Christie did with her
books where it wasn't a continuation of
the last one it wasn't just kind of
turning the crank on the same sort of
thing Christy really took a huge
different Swings with every single book
that she did in terms of not just the
mechanics of the murder mystery but also
the setting also the characters and the
themes
um so that was kind of the starting
point it's just let's write a whole new
movie that is a whole reason for being
all its own besides just doing another
one were you just listening to The
Beatles and you were like I was you know
so I'm always listening to The Beatles
but I was uh uh I kind of came up with
the metaphor of like okay it's maybe he
has some structure on his Island that's
made of glass so it's a glass Palace or
Glass Castle or something so it's
complex but you can see through it and
that's a metaphor that blonde can beat
to death so that'll be nice and then I I
got up my phone and I just searched my
music app for the word glass and Glass
Onion like popped up along with the
blondie song Heart Of Glass so I went
with Glass Onion what's the hardest
thing to crack when you're trying to
unravel a mystery like this toughest
thing is the same thing that's tough
about writing and the other story which
is figuring out
um
what what's your story and by that I
don't mean the murderer or the mystery
or anything I mean what is the thing
that the audience is going to care about
that's going to actually keep their
butts from getting numb that's going to
keep them engaged and leaning forward
um you want them leaning forward as
opposed to leaning back and like
stroking their chin right so
um and that's the same question no
matter what what type of movie you're
writing and that's always the toughest
thing could you care about and why and
can you keep an audience kind of
attached to that journey through the
whole thing Ryan what's the biggest
mystery of life I guess mystery life Ash
hmm
um many many an afternoon I've said with
a glass of ports and considered the
Billy I don't know it was the biggest
mystery of life is is what is the
biggest mystery I don't know for me
right for me right now it's where do we
set the third movie that will lead into
my next question where do we where are
you at with that like what do you
foresee as the future of the knives out
let me tell you something Ash tell me
it's one of the biggest mysteries of
life
nailed it okay so you have I mean
between the first two you have every
actor that's ever worked is in both of
these films so who's left like who's on
your wishes nobody left we're screwed
it's literally scraping the bottom of
the barrel I have to cast Noah again as
everybody he's not the same guy right
yes indeed yeah so he's the same like
character oh well we've talked about
that weather so Noah segan who plays
Trooper Wagner in the in the first movie
and plays uh yeah plays Daryl in the
second one who's kind of the joke of is
is that is it Daryl Wagner and he's kind
of gone to seed a little bit he went
through a divorce and now he's kind of
going through some stuff because I was
like is he the Common Thread yeah it's
just him being I don't think so I think
they're different characters
hey try to solve the murder mystery if
you can I don't want to tune my own horn
but it's pretty next level
[Music]